so as we officially start our discussion
on the death and return of Superman what
we're going to find is that DC actually
wastes no time and that over the course
of this video we're going to transition
from the introduction of doomsday to his
complete dismantling of the Justice
League leading into his confrontation
with Superman setting the stage for the
death of Clark Kent
so in our last video on doomsday and the
events leading up to this story we had
talked about how Superman had fallen out
of relevancy following crisis on
Infinite Earths and had been steadily
losing the battle for sales against
Batman where DC had intended to launch a
year-long event which culminated in his
marriage to Lois Lane
because DC had to work alongside the new
adventures of Lois and Clark TV show
which could write the marriage of Clark
and Lois as a part of their series and
garner more money for DC from there in
the decision was made to have the
writers of Superman stories returned to
the drawing board and mock up a new
year-long event which would focus on
returning him to relevance electing to
kill Superman rather than marry him to
Lois and the final pages of the Man of
Steel issue number 17
Superman issue number 73 Adventures of
Superman number 496 and action comics
issue number 683 DC featured an
enigmatic being shrouded in green
punching his way through a metal wall
with the caption doomsday is coming
leading to Man of Steel issue number 18
with the first full-on panel appearance
of doomsday now the way in which DC
elected to bring doomsday to the
landscape within these first few pages
was actually a slow burn what I mean
here is that rather than providing us
with a full-on display of the doomsday
that we all know instead the idea here
was to draw some measure of mystery
involving what it is that he look like
and what he was capable of the reason
for this was that historically the only
members of Superman's rogues gallery who
functioned under the banner of mystery
or those who were highly intelligent
I'd use pawns and a greater scheme to
attempt to kill Clark only revealing
themselves as the masterminds at the end
of the story however by introducing
doomsday in a mysterious manner this
essentially went towards the overarching
theme of DC changing everything we know
about the standard method of Superman
and his various battles in addition to
this over the course of the next several
pages DC continues to establish the
nature of doomsday in several ways the
first is by having him kill a bird that
stumbles into his hand now on its
surface this is pretty insignificant but
in truth it's designed to tell us
exactly what doom today is all about
unlike Superman who exists for the
preservation of life
doomsday functions as a violent being
that revels in chaos and death moreover
his love for destruction is evident and
his first arrival in a highly populated
area taken to a bridge ripping it apart
and killing people in the process
doomsday expresses no concern over the
lives of humanity
and the death and destruction that he
causes now from here we jump to doomsday
encountering the Justice League as it
existed during this time in its
continuity now for those of you who have
seen my video on the publication history
of the Justice League I'm going to ask
you to bear with me for the next few
minutes while I rehash a bit of that
information for those who haven't in my
video on the league we had talked about
how during the pre-crisis continuity
between 1960 when the team was
originally formed leading up to 1985
with crisis on Infinite Earths the
Justice League was largely composed of
DC's top heroes at the time including
Wonder Woman Aquaman flash and Green
Lantern with Batman and Superman
appearing periodically as well as a
revolving door sorts with smaller heroes
however by the time crisis on Infinite
Earths came around
DC's top-tier lineup had established
itself as being capable of drawing high
sales without coming together to battle
various foes as a result in the
post-crisis continuity DC reshuffled
both the roster and purpose of the
league and that the old guard was
removed from its lineup Justice League
of America was retitled Justice League
International operating on a broader
scale and the team was now composed of
smaller characters who would otherwise
have been unable to gain exposure on
their own as a result because this idea
proved to be successful within five
years going into the early 90s DC shook
things up again by eliminating the
Justice League international team and
splitting its roster up among two other
teams called Justice League Europe and
Justice League America with three more
titles introduced called extreme justice
Justice League task force and Justice
League quarterly now regarding the death
of Superman the team that we see here is
Justice League America where this roster
consisting a former Green Lantern Guy
Gardner who was now powered by a yellow
ring Blue Beetle Booster Gold ice who
could manipulate the cold blood wind who
held a gem allowing for unspecified but
possibly vast powers and maxima who was
an extremely powerful psychic with
superhuman strength now regarding blood
wind something I want to point out here
is that during this time in DC's
continuity this is actually Martian
Manhunter to sidetrack for a second
while this information wasn't revealed
until after the death of Superman
because blood wind derives his power
from the energy of the Dead a being
named Rob was confined within his blood
Jim and at some point in the past trap
blood wind inside his own jewel while
simultaneously forcing Martian Manhunter
to operate his blood wind while seeking
a means to allow rod to escape his
prison
Network Justice League issue 76 and 77
would see rot defeated blood when
returned to the land of the living and
martian manhunter returning to his
normal self the revelation of this
deception by rot served to retroactively
Lee explained why Martian Manhunter was
not seen during the league's battle with
doomsday and so Jamie back into the
story after being contacted regarding
doomsday ripping through outlying
territories in Ohio something to also
note here is that while the Justice
League America attempts to fight
doomsday and end his rampage at the same
time Superman is conducting an interview
with Catherine grant to sidetrack here a
catherine was originally introduced into
DC Comics in 1987 as a potential love
interest for Clark creating a new
dynamic that contained the possibility
of Superman leaving Lois Lane for
someone new where DC eventually elected
to drop this plotline catherine remained
a part of DC's continuity popping up
here and there but largely functioning
as a gossip columnist at The Daily
Planet
rather than being a tried and true
journalist like Lois Lane but within the
context of this interview the statements
of Superman are designed to juxtapose
his role in the DC Universe with his
impending death what I mean here is that
Catherine's Isis history and being a
role model for many of DC's heroes and
even anti-heroes and where the writer
doesn't say it this is meant to expand
beyond his role in the DC Universe and
encompass the influence of his creation
on the comic-book industry as a whole
since the archetype of superheroes by
way of Superman is a topic I've covered
all too often there's really no need for
us to do it again here but where the
Justice League is completely dismantled
by doomsday and their efforts to subdue
him the interview with Superman moves to
the Q&A segment when the audience is
allowed to speak with him directly in
this instance one of the members asked
Superman the question of whether or not
there's anything that he truly fears now
his answer here is extremely important
and that DC introduces something into
the story called dramatic irony within
the realm of literary works whether they
be in the form of film comics or theater
dramatic irony is the idea that the
audience is aware of something that the
hero isn't in this instance we know
Superman will die in his fight against
doomsday and that his death will not
only change the DC landscape but comics
as a whole however within this story
Superman does not know this and so his
statement of having previously
encountered being strong enough to kill
him but always coming out on top is
ironic and that it illustrates the
fact that this interview and the coming
battle were intended to be his last and
then at the end of it all when the dust
settles those in this audience and the
heroes left alive will have to face the
fact that the greatest of their heroes
had died now having said that where
Superman continues his interview by
answering the questions of the audience
the conflict between himself and
doomsday comes to a head when the entire
segment is stalked by the producer who
informs everyone that some kind of
conflict is taking place in the suburbs
of Ohio and then a villain has
completely dismantled the Justice League
taking off to meet the threat the
concern of Clark is that where the
league isn't composed of the most
powerful beings on earth these
individuals are highly formidable given
their various levels of Technology
strength psionic powers and battle
experience as such aside from maybe dark
Sider Brainiac there aren't many people
who could take the entire league down to
such a degree that they were left in
shambles furthermore with Booster Gold
as a Last Man Standing we're told that
the league has no idea of what's going
on the reason why is because between the
time when they first arrived to battle
doomsday and the current moment only a
few minutes had passed which gives us a
strong understanding of how powerful
doomsday is and that it took him less
than five minutes to crush the entire
Justice League something to also note is
that once Superman arrives in rescues
Booster Gold
doomsday is given his actual name when
booster says that doomsday is here from
here Superman and Booster descend to the
ground at which point Clark and doomsday
meet each other for the very first time
now this particular part of the story is
extremely important in that DC initiates
a paradigm shift for Superman's
character what I mean here is that where
doomsday punches Clark to virtually no
effect the battle takes place in a
neighborhood amid several onlookers
where the punch doesn't really do any
damage
doomsday kicks Superman sending him
flying through the house and out the
back door and into a tree while booster
steps in and does what he can to stop
doomsday he's ultimately unsuccessful
and that he subdued with almost no
effort and left nearly unconscious
furthermore with the various occupants
of the house caught in the battle
doomsday turns his sights to ice bring
her ribs in the process with the
intention of killing the woman and her
child
however with Superman stepping back into
the fight and telling the woman to leave
with her child an older son as well as a
remainder of the Justice League
regrouping the entire battle turns into
a kind of last man at the Alamo
situation with
we combined their powers together in an
effort to defeat doomsday before his
rampage can extend any further what's
also interesting here is that where the
origin of doomsday came after this story
we can combine the two elements together
in establishing that where he can adapt
to whatever killed him
he's also capable of adapting to whoever
agrees fighting at the time the evidence
for this comes when the combined forces
of blood wind Guy Gardner Booster Gold
and Maxima proved to not be enough in
that doomsday is capable of withstanding
all other attacks in addition to this
because he can resist their power
everyone in the league - Superman
literally drain every ounce of energy
they have until they can't give any more
and end up having to drop out of the
fight now the purpose of this is again
to weed out the league and essentially
empty the field of everyone who could do
battle against doomsday except for
Superman however something I also want
to do here is have a quick discussion on
Batman Wonder Woman the flash in Hal
Jordan with a story like this which
involves Superman and the Justice League
fighting against doomsday we would
normally expect and eventually see the
rest of DC's core lineup make some kind
of an appearance but because DC was
looking to create a situation where this
question wouldn't be asked by fans who
were following the complete continuity
at the time a series of stories were
produced which answered this question
for Batman his character was dealing
with the prelude to the nightfall story
arc involving the return of black mask
metalhead and a host of other villains
all of whom had launched an attack
against the bat family and Commissioner
Gordon at the orders of baned
underwriter George Perez
Wonder Woman had been trapped in deep
space by way of the actions of a villain
named Thomas Asquith Rudolph where she
was eventually taken prisoner on a war
planet under the writing of dick
Giordano Hal Jordan was in space
alongside the rest of the Green Lantern
Corps dealing with the return of Crona
during the three-part series the third
law and I have no idea where the flash
was but regardless the result was at
among the core members of DC's lineup
Superman was effectively the last man
standing as the only individual capable
of dealing with the threat that doomsday
represented now one of the most
important things that come out of this
portion of the story is the fact that
Superman actually Gamble's the lives of
innocent civilians potentially leaving
them to die the reason why this matters
is that where his Golden Age counterpart
routinely kill people once Superman had
become a larger-than-life character in
DC Comics during the Silver Age there
was a strict no killing policy meaning
that while
Steele would pummel villains to the
point of near death he would never
actually kill them more so than that and
virtually all instances Superman would
actually abandon his attempts to fight a
villain in order to ensure innocent
lives were spared during a battle now to
focus a little more on this the no kill
rule of Superman's history wasn't
necessarily a rule laid down by editors
so much as it was a rule that evolved on
its own what I mean here is that during
the 1950's when Superman was increasing
in popularity under Mort Weisinger
because the need was there for villains
who could consistently return rather
than forcing riders to create new
villains all the time it made no sense
to have the Man of Steel engage in a
fight with the antagonist and then kill
him due to the fact that it would
eliminate the opportunity for the
villain to return instead the tradition
was born allowing for morality tales
where criminals could learn from their
actions finding redemption in the
process while simultaneously allowing
for the most hardened villains to
continue coming back challenging
Superman in various fights now having
said that in his conflict when one of
the houses is set ablaze allowing
doomsday the opportunity to get away
Superman seems to cast aside the idea of
saving the innocent civilians in favor
of ensuring that doomsday does not
escape now for those of you looking to
the idea of Superman letting these
people die this is actually not the case
and instead Superman focuses on dealing
with doomsday as fast as possible with
the intention of returning and helping
the innocent people now something that I
thought was really cool about this was
that it's actually a classic example of
game theory to sidetrack here game
theory is the idea of using mathematical
probabilities to determine it the most
likely course of action someone will
take when the success of their choices
depends on the choices of others in this
instance was Superman dealing with
doomsday the success of his ability to
incapacitate his foe depends on the
success of the Justice League to muster
the little energy they have left rescue
the innocence and escape the building
before anyone dies however because
doomsday had released such a brutal
assault on the league itself putting
Blue Beetle in a coma in the process the
issue Superman faces is that he may end
up having to fight a battle on two
fronts and then not only will he have to
find a way to subdue doomsday and save
the residents but if the fight extends
to a populated area Superman will also
have to focus on the occupants within
the city keep them safe while battling
doomsday at the same time realizing the
doomsday possesses the ability to leap
rather than fly the idea comes to
Superman
and to be redos day within the earth
itself deep enough that even if it can
hold him forever the weight of the soil
should be heavy enough that it can
temporarily trap doomsday allowing
Clarke to tend to the innocence rescue
them and turn his attention back to the
fight in addition to this once he
arrives we find the blood Wynn had
successfully managed to free the mother
and the youngest child while the eldest
son had gone to the paramedics for a
regarding his own injuries taking the
mother and her child out of the flames
and bringing them to the ambulance for
analysis of their injuries DC began the
process of dropping hints regarding
Martian Manhunter impersonating blood
wind and the rather than sticking around
he simply teleports away from here we
move away from the conflict between
Superman and doomsday and travel to
Metropolis to pick up with Lois Lane
Supergirl and Lex Luthor
now something I want to point out here
is that this version of Lex that we see
and this story is both the real Lex and
a clone at the same time in an ongoing
story arc spanning several Superman
titles including Action Comics Superman
and Man of Steel Lex Luthor had acquired
a piece of Kryptonite and work
constantly due to its ability to keep
Superman away however the result was
that Lex to develop cancer leading to
him faking his death and planting his
consciousness in the mind of a younger
clone this version of Lex as we see him
here with red hair and a beard is that
very clone functioning as a 21 year old
version of Lex with the real Lex
Luthor's mind operating inside something
to also note is that if you recall my
video on Supergirl we had talked about
how the original Kara zor-el had died
fighting in crisis on Infinite Earths
with the post-crisis version being a
synthetic organism from another reality
this version of Supergirl was known as
matrix but and not yet absorbed Linda
Danvers meaning that for all intents and
purposes with the exception of a few
extra abilities in the eyes of the world
this is the one true Supergirl now on
its face where the intention of
Supergirl is to step in and help
Superman overcome doomsday the idea of
Lex is that she needs to stay behind in
order to ensure a contingency plan
allowing for someone to battle doomsday
if Superman dies I would argue however
that the position of Lex is that because
of his hatred for Superman rather than
allowing Supergirl to join in the fray
leading to the likely defeat of doomsday
because she's made to stay behind
Superman will likely die which would see
Lex's goals come to fruition and so
transitioning back to the conflict with
maxima arriving and appearing to be the
last member of a League left capable of
fighting
when she throws doomsday into a building
the initial response of Superman is that
there could have been innocent people
inside now this isn't really meant to be
a major part of the story and is
actually only really designed to
continue the idea that despite
everything that's happening Clark is
maintaining his role as attempting to
preserve the lives of innocent people
but in the momentary distraction
Superman seizes doomsday from behind
attempting to allow Maxima the
opportunity to use her vast strength to
pummel doomsday but because the strength
and speed of doomsday is increasing as
he fights he proves to be too fast for
either Superman or maxima breaking
himself free in the process and
continuing his rampage however because
Maxima is less restrained than Superman
and fights more with her emotions than
with a clear mind rather than coming at
doomsday reasonably she instead rips a
light pole out of the ground with the
intention of using it to impale doomsday
hoping to kill him in the process and so
despite the warning of Superman the
electric charge from the light pole arcs
and in doing so causes a massive
explosion which knocks out Superman and
Maxima allowing doomsday to move towards
his final destination of Metropolis and
so following this and as we bring this
video to a close the scene is met with
the arrival of Guardian now to be honest
my history on his character is a little
fuzzy and the only information I found
on him came from the DC wiki but because
user editable sources like Wikipedia
czar unreliable I don't rely on them and
I won't do so here either instead the
only information I recall from the
comics of the Guardian is that at one
point he was a person named Jim Harper
who is introduced in 1942 as DC's
counterpart to Marvel's captain America
and at at some point a series of clowns
were made due to Harper having died but
regardless the arrival of Guardian
allows for a conversation with Superman
where he reveals that because Maximas
actions and fighting recklessly and
without thought to the consequences save
for the goal of killing doomsday the
only person Superman can rely on to
bring this rampage to an end is himself
with having said we're going to bring
this video to an end and let me know
what you guys think about this story of
the death of Superman so far I think
it's kind of man it's all right and I
will catch you guys later peace